(music)
- My name's Dylan Penningroth,
I'm a Professor of Law and
History here at Berkeley,
and I'm chair of the Jefferson
Memorial Lectures Committee.
Just a little bit of background
about these lectures,
they were established way
back in 1980, excuse me,
1944, through a bequest
from Elizabeth Bonestell
and her husband Cutler L.
Bonestell of San Francisco,
and the Bonestells cared
deeply about history,
and they hoped that these
lectures would encourage students,
faculty, scholars, and area residents
to study the legacy of Thomas Jefferson,
and to explore values inherent
to American democracy.
And past lecturers, who have
included Annette Gordon-Reed,
Senator Alan Simpson,
Senator Elizabeth Warren,
Archibald Cox, and most
recently, George Packer,
have delivered Jefferson Lectures
on early American history,
about Jefferson himself,
and on American institutions and policies
in politics, economics,
education, and law.
Now, before I go any further,
I have to say that any event
like this is a group effort,
as any of you who have
organized one will know,
and the committee, which
includes Mark Brilliant,
Paul Pearson, Wendy Silver, Karen Tawny,
Christopher Tomlins, and I join me
in thanking Whitney
Mellow, Sevala Travinsky,
and especially Ellen Gobler,
who you just saw up here,
for their deft and tactful
handling of all the logistics.
So we're pleased on behalf
of the Graduate Division
to present this year's speaker
in the Jefferson Memorial
Lecture Series, David Cole.
So in July, 2016,
David Cole was named
National Legal Director
of the American Civil Liberties
Union, our country's largest
and oldest civil liberties organization.
So in July, 2016, you may remember,
The New York Times gave
Hillary Clinton a 74% chance
of becoming president, it
looked like things were going
to be, well, maybe not all
right, but at least aight.
(audience laughs)
Right?
(audience murmurs)
We all know what happened next, and thanks
to Robert Mueller, we're slowly
finding out how it happened,
now, David Cole has been at the forefront
of those who are fighting the
consequences of what happened.
Since that fateful November,
this already busy man
has become even busier,
as National Legal Director, he oversees
about 1,400 civil liberties
lawsuits, and manages over,
excuse me, 300 staff
attorneys at ACLU headquarters
in New York, and affiliate
offices in all 50 states,
Puerto Rico, and Washington, DC.
There has never been a better time
to become what the first
George Bush once scorned,
"a card carrying member of the ACLU."
Now, Cole was law clerk
to Judge Arlin Adams
of the Third Circuit Court of Appeals,
he was a staff attorney
at the Center for Constitutional Rights,
and he taught constitutional law
and criminal justice at Georgetown,
as the Honorable George
J. Mitchell Professor
in Law and Public Policy.
He's argued a number of
major civil liberties cases,
including Texas versus Johnson,
which struck down state laws
banning flag desecration,
National Endowment for
the Arts versus Finley,
which contested content
restrictions on NEA funding,
and Holder versus
Humanitarian Law Project,
which challenged the
legality of a provision
in the USA Patriot Act barring,
quote, "material support,"
end quote, to foreign
terrorist organizations.
In December, 2017, he
argued Masterpiece Cake Shop
versus Colorado Civil Rights Commission,
in which the rights of free
exercise, or free expression,
and the right in public accommodations
to protection against bias based
on sexual orientation
come together in conflict,
or what the legal historian
Rebecca J. Scott has called,
in another context, "public
rights, or the equal dignity
"of citizens in the public
sphere, these are the stakes."
Cole has written or edited 10 books,
he's Legal Affairs
Correspondent for The Nation,
and a regular commentator
on National Public Radio.
He's received two honorary degrees,
and many awards for his civil liberties
and human rights work, including, in 2013,
the first Norman Dorsen
Presidential Prize from the ACLU,
awarded to an academic
for lifetime commitment
to civil liberties.
For his Jefferson
Lecture, Cole asks, quote,
"What does the first year of fighting
"for liberty tell us
about constitutional law,
"and the future of civil liberties
"and civil rights in the United States?"
Please join me in welcoming
David Cole to Berkeley.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you so much for that
very lovely introduction,
I, when I get an introduction like that,
I'm often, it often calls to
mind what Justice Brennan used
to say, when he got similar
over-the-top introductions,
he would say, you know, "I
wish my parents had been here
"to hear it, my father
would have been proud,
"and my mother would have believed it."
(audience laughs)
So, and I am delighted
to be giving the Thomas
Jefferson lecture, I was,
earlier today, interviewed
for a video presentation,
and the, here at Berkeley,
and the person who was
doing the taping referred
to me as Mr. Jefferson, so I
thought that was interesting.
(audience laughs)
But I will, I'll talk mostly
about the last year, and more
about what Donald Trump can
teach us about civil liberties
than what Thomas Jefferson can teach us.
My principal
message here is that
while this is a dark time,
and there's no question
that it is a dark time
in our, in our country,
for a variety of reasons,
and for a variety of
segments of our population,
it is also a time of opportunity.
And I think a time of,
of hope,
and secondly,
that we will determine
how this time is ultimately viewed
in history,
and if we respond
by exercising our civil liberties,
we can, I think, transform
what is a very dark time
into essentially a catalyst
for a renewed progressive movement.
So it's easy, I think, to convince people
that these are dark times,
and I'm sure you've heard many
talks, and many, you know,
guests on talk shows talk
about how dark it is,
but I really want to look at
the other side of the coin,
and that is where opportunity lies.
But first, in terms of, you know,
how things have changed, Dylan mentioned
that I was hired in July, 2016,
and I was hired, I was
recruited for the job
by the Executive Director of the ACLU,
Anthony Romero, who came
down to Washington, DC,
where I was teaching at
Georgetown, and he said,
"David, you know, I've got
an offer you can't refuse.
"You have been teaching
constitutional law,
"practicing constitutional
law for 30 something years
"under a conservative
majority Supreme Court.
"Just think what it would be like
"to run the ACLU's legal docket,
"and especially it's Supreme Court work
"under a liberal majority Supreme Court."
And, of course, The New
York Times may have had it
at 74%, that Hillary Clinton would win,
I had it at 100%, that
Hillary Clinton would win,
and I think most of the
people I knew had it at 100%,
and so she would, of
course, name the successor
to Justice Scalia, and we would have,
for the first time in four decades,
a liberal majority Supreme Court.
So I, of course, I signed
on the bottom line,
I went to law school back in the 1980s,
and my professors were
all people who had come up
and become lawyers and law professors
in the civil rights movement
under the watchful eye
of the Warren Court, the
Supreme Court under the tenure
of Earl Warren, the most
progressive Supreme Court
in the history of this
country, and that's the vision
of constitutional law that they taught me.
And then I graduated, and went out,
and practiced under a conservative
majority Supreme Court
for three plus decades, so
I thought this was a great,
a great opportunity, I
signed on the bottom line,
I didn't put in a conditional what-if,
because there was no what if, right?
And I immediately, I
didn't start immediately,
because I was finishing up
my teaching at Georgetown,
but I, you know, immediately
tasked the ACLU lawyers
to write memos on how we could
advance constitutional law
under this liberal Supreme Court
that we were sure to be operating under,
and those are really interesting memos.
They're now in the wastebasket.
And obviously, everything
changed on November 8th.
The, I still hadn't started
to work for the ACLU, but the,
the Executive Director decided
to introduce me to the national staff
at a national staff
meeting, which he scheduled
for November 9th, the
morning after the election.
You can imagine that staff meeting was not
about introducing me,
it was about what had,
what had just, what had just
transpired, and people were,
you know, many of the staff were,
you know, in shock, as I'm sure, you know,
many of your students
were, many of the people
in this room, probably, were in shock
because no one ever
thought this could happen,
and everyone was very concerned
about what it might,
what it might portend.
And it did change, in many
ways, in fundamental ways,
the way that we operate,
but in other ways, no,
I mean, we, we've been around since 1920.
We've sued Republican presidents,
we've sued Democratic
presidents, we sued the Bushes,
we sued Clinton, we sued Obama,
so in that respect, you
know, we will sue Trump.
We have sued Trump, that's
not that much of a change,
but we went from the possibility
of working on offense,
and having an inside game
with a Justice Department that shared some
of our most basic beliefs and values
to having to play a
largely defensive game,
and one in which we,
we have to rely largely
on an outside game, rather
than an inside game.
But, in many ways, it's times like this
when organizations like
ours are so critical,
and so important, and one of the reasons
that I feel buoyed and hopeful
in this time is the response
of the citizenry to the
election of Donald Trump.
So Donald Trump walks
like an authoritarian,
he talks like an authoritarian,
but he doesn't rule like an authoritarian,
and the reason he doesn't
rule like an authoritarian,
at least thus far, is because he can't,
because there's been significant
resistance from citizens,
from courts, from civil
society in a variety of ways,
and those checks are absolutely critical.
So, you know, there are
many examples of the,
of the response to
President Trump's election.
Here, this is our first response,
"we'll see you in court,"
and for a long time, this
was, this was what you saw,
Donald Trump's visage on the front page
of the ACLU website, and
we, two days after that,
that staff, that staff
meeting, on November 9th,
we published in The New York Times
and the Washington Post this letter
to president-elect Trump,
"For nearly 100 years,
"the ACLU has stood as the
nation's premier defender
"of freedom and justice for all,
"as you assume the
nation's highest office,
"we must ask you now, as president-elect,
"to reconsider and change course
"on certain campaign
promises you have made."
And we then went through the
campaign promises he had made,
including the Muslim ban, and said,
if you carry these promises
through, we'll see you in court.
And that's what, that's
what we have, we have done,
we have sued the president
over the Muslim ban,
on many occasions, and I'll
come back to that in a moment.
We've sued him over the
attempts to deport Dreamers,
people who have, have the
protection of the, of DACA,
those are the young people who
were brought here illegally
by their parents, and are, but at no fault
of their own, and are undocumented,
we sued him over his Voter
Integrity Commission,
which was essentially designed to try to
create the basis for suppressing the vote.
We sued him
over his,
his administration's policy
of obstructing access
to young undocumented women who are
in federal custody
here, and seek an abortion.
And his,
his choice to head up the
Office of Refugee Resettlement,
a man named Scott Lloyd, who
has no history or experience
in immigration, but is an
ardent anti-choice person,
has taken it upon himself
to essentially bar the door.
When young women who are
detained because they're,
they've been, you know,
captured as undocumented here,
they learn that they're
pregnant, they choose
to exercise their constitutional right
to obtain an abortion,
he has, time and again,
essentially blocked the door, and said,
"I'm not going to facilitate
your obtaining an abortion."
"I'm not gonna facilitate,"
how is he facilitating the
woman obtaining an abortion?
By opening the gate, so that
she can leave the facility
that she's detained in, in order to go
to a clinic where she can
get medical treatment.
And so we've sued him to challenge
that direct obstruction
of the right to choose
to terminate a pregnancy.
We've sued him over the
transgender military ban,
which he introduced via Twitter,
without any consultation with
the Joint Chiefs of Staff,
who had determined that there was no need
to bar transgender individuals
from serving in the military.
We've sued him over a policy
that would allow employers
to deny contraceptive
coverage to their employees
through their health insurance,
if they object to their female
employees getting access
to contraceptive coverage,
putting the employer's moral
or religious beliefs over
the rights of women to,
to full medical coverage.
So we've sued him time
and again, we've had,
we have five cases in the
Supreme Court this term,
and in all five, Trump
is on the other side,
the Masterpiece Cake Shop
case, the Justice Department,
for the first time in
its history is supporting
a constitutional exemption
to a non-discrimination law.
The Justice Department enforces
non-discrimination law,
that's one of the central responsibilities
of the Justice Department, and so for them
to support a constitutional exemption
to non-discrimination law is remarkable,
and indeed, unprecedented.
We're suing, we're on the other side
in a case involving Ohio's practice
of purging voters from the voter
rolls if they fail to vote,
and for 20 years, the Justice Department,
under Republican, as well as
Democratic administrations,
supported the view that we're
articulating in that case,
that the Motor Voter law
prohibits that practice.
And in fact, the Justice
Department filed an amicus brief,
a friend of the court brief, in our case,
supporting our side in
the Court of Appeals.
But when we prevailed, and
when Ohio took the case
to the Supreme Court, and
Donald Trump was elected,
and Jeff Sessions was appointed,
they reversed their position,
a 20 year consistent position
on the statute, flipped sides in the case,
and are opposing us.
We are, we're suing
over your privacy rights
with respect to the cell,
the data on your cellphone,
and the Trump administration's
arguing it should be able
to get the data on your cellphone,
as to where you, where
you are at any given time,
without a warrant,
without going to a judge.
And, of course, we sued
him over the travel ban,
that is also before the Supreme Court,
now, for the second time this term,
and will be argued in April.
So, so we told them,
"We'll see you in court,"
and we have indeed seen them in court,
and by and large, the courts
have stood up to the president.
So the courts have
enjoined the Muslim ban,
repeatedly, three different versions
of the Muslim ban have
been enjoined, repeatedly.
The court's enjoined the
transgender military ban,
the court's barred the Office
of Refugee Resettlement
from keeping women from their
right to, to obtain abortion,
the courts have rescinded
President Trump's rescission
of DACA, the protection for the Dreamers.
The courts have enjoined the policy
that would allow employers to
deny contraceptive coverage
to their employees if they object.
So, so by and large,
the courts have stood up
to the president, and I
think that's, you know,
as it should be, it's not as it always is,
and, of course, we have not yet heard
from the Supreme Court on
any of these questions,
and that's where the rubber
ultimately meets the road.
But in a time of unified government,
that is, the same party
controlling the presidency,
both houses of Congress, and, indeed,
right now, the Supreme Court,
the
courts, nonetheless, continue
to play an important
role in checking abuse.
And why is that, well, one, the politics
of the courts lags behind
the politics of the moment,
because judges are appointed
by a particular party
at a particular time, but
then they serve for life,
and so the courts'
outlook changes much more slowly than the,
than Congress or the
president, number one.
Number two, the courts are,
their self-definition is
to be independent checks
applying law to politics,
and while there is obviously
reason to be skeptical
that they always do that,
and that it's possible
to separate law from politics,
it is critical to their
legitimacy as institutional actors
to hold true to that ideal,
and so courts do,
in many instances, hold
true to that ideal.
I think, in this instance,
it's also the case
that courts tend to be
establishment focused,
you don't get to be a judge
by being a rebel, right?
You, so courts are establishment oriented,
whether they're, whether
a judge is appointed
by a Democrat, or a Republican,
they have an interest in the status quo,
the law has an interest in
preserving the status quo,
and making sure that people, you know,
can sort of plan their
lives, go about their lives
without getting too disrupted.
And President Trump
doesn't seem to care all
that much about the status quo,
and he is quite, in
virtually every respect,
a challenge to the status quo.
And in his attitudes towards
constitutional norms,
constitutional rights, and,
indeed, the courts themselves,
he is not only threatening
the rights of individuals,
but threatening the
institutional role of courts.
So when the first nationwide
ban on the,
travel ban was issued by the
judge in Washington state,
Trump tweeted, and referred
to the judge as a "so-called
judge," all right?
So when the president is,
shows utter disregard
for basic underpinnings
and foundations of our
constitutional system,
it is not surprising
that courts will be
part of the resistance,
and indeed, they have, they have stood up
for the rule of law, for
rights, at least thus far,
against the, against the president.
But
courts are
by no means enough,
and it's not these, this
handful of decisions
that really makes me hopeful,
you know, it is,
it is much more the other forms of checks
and balances that operate at a time
when one party controls the
executive, the Congress,
the Supreme Court, and, while we're at it,
two thirds of the state,
of state governments.
And that is
not formal separation of powers,
but
the informal checks and balances
of civil society,
the press, the academy,
and religious organizations,
and civil society
non-profit organizations,
like the ACLU, or Planned Parenthood.
At times like this, those are
critical
potential sites of resistance,
indeed, that's why,
when authoritarians take power,
and exercise authoritarian control,
don't just walk and talk
like an authoritarian,
but rule like an authoritarian,
as we've seen in Hungary,
in Poland, these are their targets,
right, they target the courts,
but they also target the universities,
they target the press,
they target civil society,
because they, and they
often target religion,
because these are all places
where citizens come together
and act collectively in ways
that can hold the government accountable,
and can resist abuses of authority.
This is why the first
amendment is so important,
it's not just, the first
amendment doesn't just protect
a right to express yourself,
to discover who you are,
to be an autonomous human being,
it protects that value, to be sure.
But it also is a critical,
plays a critical structural role
in checking abuse, and it does that
by protecting precisely
these forms of civil
society checks and balances,
a free press, free exercise of religion,
freedom of speech, freedom of association,
and freedom of assembly,
this is how the people hold
a government accountable.
And what I find most encouraging
about the, the Trump era,
is
how energized
that civil society sector is.
And we saw it, you know,
the day after the
president was inaugurated,
with the women's march,
and just a remarkable,
nation-wide, world-wide uprising
of people who came together
to stand up against
what this newly inaugurated
president stood for.
And we've seen it since then
in the airport demonstrations,
in the DACA demonstrations, in the,
the town halls to protest the efforts
to repeal the Affordable Care Act,
in the elections, special
elections in Alabama
and Virginia, in which people who care
about civil rights and civil
liberties came out in force,
and elected
people who, who, representatives who stood
for those values in places
where that was unthinkable,
before Donald Trump was elected.
We've seen it at the ACLU, I mean,
many people say to me, you know, well,
"You started in January, David,
you know, how's it going?"
And I say, "Well, not bad,
before I started working
"at the ACLU, we had
400,000 members, today,
"we have 1.75 million
members," pretty good, right?
(audience applauds)
Now, that's the difference,
for those of you who are students,
that's the difference between
correlation and causation,
I don't think I can
take credit for much of
that increase in our membership,
my dad did join, so I get
that one, but otherwise, Donald
Trump gets credit, right?
But really, it's the American
people who get credit,
they have recognized
that in a time like this,
organizations like ours,
and it's not just ours,
Planned Parenthood has
seen unprecedented support,
the Legal Defense Fund,
lots of newfound support,
the press, The New York
Times subscriptions,
Washington Post subscriptions
have never been higher,
people are responding
to the threat of Trump
in the way that they know best,
which is by engaging,
by engaging collectively
through the institutions of civil society
that can play a role in curtailing these,
these sorts of abuses.
So it's been
kind of a wild ride at,
at the ACLU, I mean, one of my,
the legal director of the Chicago,
of the Illinois ACLU said to me, you know,
shortly I had begun, he
said, "You know, David,
"it's not fair, you started to become,
"you became the legal
director of the ACLU at a time
"when it's popular to be the director,
"to be with the ACLU, right," and he's
from the Illinois ACLU, the
one that defended the rights
of the Nazis to mark in
Skokie, so he should know.
But we have, you know, in
addition to our newfound members,
we've had thousands of
people coming forward
to volunteer, lawyers,
non-lawyers, tech people,
artists, we've had people like Tom Hanks,
and Tina Fey, and Usher, and all kinds
of other artists, way too cool for me
to have ever heard of them
do fundraisers for the ACLU,
the, one day I walked into my office,
and there were all these big boxes
in the hallway outside of my office,
big, black boxes, and all
these cameras, and what was it,
it was Vogue magazine,
who had come to the office
of the ACLU
to do a feature on women of the ACLU.
I can guarantee you that in the 100 years
that the ACLU has been around,
there has never been a
feature on women of the ACLU,
much less in Vogue
magazine, and those big,
black boxes were filled
with really fancy clothes
and shoes that they dressed the women in,
because we, 'cause, you know, women
of the don't ACLU don't dress sufficiently
for Vogue magazine, so Vogue dressed them.
But really, you know,
quite, quite something,
and, you know, it's,
it is that support
that I think, you know, supports all
of us as we do the work,
as we do the work that we, that we do.
So let me talk a little bit about
how this, sort of give an
example, sort of how this
works.
So
let's, let's, you know,
think back to the Muslim ban.
The Muslim ban was President
Trump's first major initiative,
and that was not a coincidence, he chose,
for his first major
initiative, it was issued
on January 26th, six days
after he took office,
targeting foreign nationals,
targeting Muslim foreign
nationals in the name
of protecting American's
national security.
Now, historically,
that kind of measure does pretty well,
politically, in the United States,
and in other countries, as well, that is,
if the government says to the people, hey,
you're under threat,
we're here to protect you,
and we're not gonna take
away your rights to do this,
we're gonna take away the
rights of somebody else,
and the somebody else are foreigners,
and not just foreigners,
but Muslim foreigners.
In the aftermath of 9/11, President Bush
and the Justice Department rounded up
over 5,000 foreign nationals,
Arab and Muslim foreign nationals,
and detained them on suspicion
that they might be involved with 9/11.
None of them turned out
to be involved with 9/11,
but it wasn't, it didn't cause an outcry,
and the message was, we're targeting them,
not you, and we're seeking to protect you.
The same thing happened in 1920,
when there were a series
of terrorist bombings,
this is as close as I get
to Thomas Jefferson, 1920,
there were a series of terrorist
bombings, and the response
to those terrorist bombings
was the Palmer Raids,
in which the government went out,
and rounded up thousands
of foreign nationals,
none of whom had anything to
do with the terrorist bombings.
And again, not a huge outcry
from the American people.
But this time was very different,
this time there was
resistance from day one.
The order was issued on a Friday,
that night we filed the
first case challenging
the,
the ban,
on behalf of two young
Iraqi men who had been
given visas to come here after working
with our military in Iraq.
They were stopped at JFK
airport, because they were
from Iraq, and the Muslim ban
covered anyone who was coming
from Iraq, even those who had
visas, who had been vetted,
who had been cleared, and
who'd been given visas
because they had sacrificed for us.
And so we sued that
night, with the help of a,
of a clinic of law students
at Yale Law School.
And the next day, Saturday,
a remarkable thing happened.
Tens of thousands of Americans rushed out
to airports to demonstrate,
and this was remarkable
for at least two reasons, one,
this was not the way
we historically respond
when the government
targets them to protect us.
People were going out to airports not
to demonstrate for their own rights,
but for the rights of
others, for the rights
of foreign nationals, for
the rights of Muslims.
But the second thing that
makes it remarkable is
where these demonstrations took place,
they were at airports,
I don't know about you,
but the last place I want to be,
unless I have to go somewhere,
is an airport, right?
It's a soul crushing environment, and yet,
tens of thousands of Americans
got off their couches,
and went out to demonstrate,
to protest on behalf
of the other, and against
the Trump travel ban.
They went to airports like
JFK, and Boston Logan Airport,
and SFO, where there's plenty
of international flights coming in,
and people were getting stopped.
But they also went out to
wholly domestic airports,
where there were no international
travelers whatsoever,
people were just, people
were primed, and ready to,
to stand up, and to act, to engage.
And it wasn't just, it wasn't just people,
ordinary people, it was also
all manner of civil society,
so ultimately, the leading, the presidents
of all the leading universities signed
a letter opposing the Trump ban,
the leading science
organizations all signed
a petition opposing the Trump ban, the,
the CEOs of the largest and
most successful corporations
in Silicon Valley
submitted an amicus brief
opposing the Trump travel ban.
And even national security
officials came together
to oppose the Trump
travel ban, that weekend,
Michael Hayden,
who was a,
the head of the NSA and the CIA,
under George W. Bush,
he's a, he's a defender
of the CIA's interrogation
slash torture program,
I've debated him on
several occasions on that,
and yet, that weekend, he tweeted,
"How about that, ACLU
and I in same corner."
Dick Cheney said this was
un-American, Dick Cheney.
(audience laughs)
And Berkeley's own John
Yoo, who came to prominence
by writing the memos as a lawyer
in the Justice Department
that authorized the use
of torture by President Bush,
he wrote an oped for The
New York Times, saying,
"This time executive
power has gone too far."
So there was a remarkable
voicing of resistance from people,
from ordinary citizens at airports,
to the leading university,
scientific organizations,
businesses, and former
government officials.
We had a, that was all on that
weekend, so that, our case
that we filed that Friday night,
was scheduled for an emergency hearing on
that Saturday night,
and it went out on Twitter,
as these things do,
that there was a hearing
on the Muslim ban, on Saturday night,
at the Brooklyn Federal
Courthouse, and this was the scene,
I'm gonna see if this works,
this was the scene outside
of the courthouse.
- [Crowd] ACLU, we are
here, we stand with you!
- Over 1,000 people
surrounded the courthouse
on a Saturday night, like, you know,
how often do you think
on a Saturday night,
"Hey, what do you want to
do, it's a Saturday night,
"let's go down to the courthouse."
They came and surrounded the courthouse,
it was a cold night, January 27th,
it was almost as cold as it is here today.
(audience laughs)
And they were chanting, "ACLU,
"we are here, we stand with you."
Again, never in the history
of the ACLU has that happened,
and indeed, shortly thereafter,
the ACLU lawyers walked out
of the courthouse to announce to the crowd
that the judge has issued
the first injunction
against the travel ban.
So, and these things are not,
and then, then the court
in Washington state
issued the nationwide ban,
and then those cases went up on appeal,
and the Courts of Appeals
affirmed those injunctions,
and Trump initially
made all kinds of noises
about appealing, but ultimately decided
to put out a second version
of the ban, and that, too,
was struck down, and he's took
that up to the Supreme Court,
but then just as the court
was to hear argument in
that case, he put out a
third version of the ban.
And that one has been
challenged in the courts,
as well, and has been struck
down by district courts,
by the Court of Appeals
in the Ninth Circuit here,
and the Court of Appeals
for the Fourth Circuit
in Richmond, Virginia, and will be heard
in the Supreme Court.
So this is an example, I think, of this,
the combination of civil society activism
and courts playing a
critically effective role
in checking the president's abuses.
And if you look at, at history,
what you often see is that dark times
can lead us to positive results
if,
if people respond
to those dark times by
engaging, by resisting,
and by acting collectively
through civil society
to advance a brighter future.
So the first take, the first amendment,
the first amendment today
is pretty well settled,
there is a very strong presumption
that the government cannot
suppress your speech,
even if you're advocating crime,
unless your speech is,
is intended and likely
to produce imminent criminal
conduct, a very high bar.
It was established in a
case involving the KKK,
Brandenburg versus Ohio, 1960s.
Similarly, it is established
that you have a right
to associate even with organizations
that engage in criminal activity,
as long as you don't specifically intend
to further the illegal
ends of the organization.
That, too, was established in the 1960s
in a series of Communist Party cases.
The argument of the government had been
the Communist Party engages
in illegal activity,
it seeks to overthrow the United States
by force and violence, that's a crime,
and therefore anyone who's associated
with the Communist Party
can be denied their job,
can be locked up, punished,
deported, et cetera.
But ultimately, the court ruled no,
you have a right to join
the Communist Party,
you have a right to support
as long as you don't specifically intend
to further its illegal ends.
So those are tremendously
significant protections
of our first amendment
freedoms, but they came out,
where did they come from?
They came from a history
of government abuse
of first amendment rights,
they came from decades
of the McCarthy era, and the red scare,
and the targeting of anti-war
activists during World War I,
and the targeting of anarchists in the,
in the teens and the 1920s, and
it was out of the experience
of abuse
that the court ultimately adopted
a powerfully protective
view of the first amendment.
And it, the court didn't do it on its own,
it was through the work of labor unions,
of the Communist Party, of organizations
that represented the Communist Party,
the National Lawyers Guild,
and the National Emergency
Civil Liberties Committee,
of organizations like the ACLU
to advance a broader protection,
broader understanding of
first amendment protections.
In my book, Engines of Liberty,
which I wrote the year
before I joined the ACLU,
I looked at a couple other
examples, one is the,
how did the right to bear arms
go from being dismissed as a fraud in 1990
by the Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court, Warren Berger,
a conservative Republican
appointee, who said that,
"The notion that the
second amendment protects
"an individual right to bear arms is one
"of the greatest frauds perpetrated
"on the American people in
my lifetime," that was 1990.
How did it go from being
dismissed as a fraud
by a conservative Supreme Court justice
to being recognized as a
constitutional right just less
than two decades later, in 2008?
And what the answer is,
as you, I'm sure, know, the
National Rifle Association.
It was the work of the
NRA, a group of citizens,
committed to a particular
vision of constitutional law,
one that had been dismissed
by the Supreme Court as fraudulent,
one that had been rejected
by the federal courts
for 100 years, it was their
work, their political work
that led, that created the possibility
that this right could be recognized.
And what, what sparked their
engagement in this quest?
The NRA has been around for a long time,
but the NRA has not been
a political organization
for a long time, the NRA started out,
was founded after the Civil War
by Union generals who were abashed
at how bad shots the Union Army was,
and so they created the NRA to, like,
train people to be better marksmen.
And it was a marksmanship
and hunting organization
for, you know, over 100
years, then, in the '60s,
there was the uprisings, and the violence,
and the assassinations, and it led 1968
to the most aggressive federal
gun control legislation
in American history, the
Gun Control Act of 1968.
And it was only in response to that,
considered a disaster by
the NRA and its members,
that they created a political arm,
and undertook a political campaign,
which was designed to instantiate
and establish an individual
right to bear arms.
And they did it incrementally,
they did it in the states,
they did it through legislation,
they did it through electoral politics,
they did it by arguing cases
in state court, and they,
and ultimately, they were able to
put, get all 50 states
on board as protecting an
individual right to bear arms
by the time the Supreme Court
took up the question in 2008.
So under state law, or
state constitutions,
the states had already
recognized an individual right
to bear arms, they got
Congress to support the notion
of an individual right to
bear arms in several pieces
of legislation, they
got the executive branch
to support an individual
right to bear arms
when George Bush was
elected with their support,
and John Ashcroft was
made the Attorney General,
a longtime NRA member,
and they immediately wrote the
Attorney General, and said,
"Dear John, what do you think
"about the Justice
Department's longtime view
"that the second amendment doesn't protect
"an individual right to bear arms?"
And he wrote back immediately, and said,
"I think it's crazy," and
he reversed a position
that the Justice Department
had taken for decades,
and got a 100 page memo written
by the Office of Legal Counsel
on why there is an individual
right to bear arms.
And so when the case came up
to the Supreme Court in 2008,
the NRA had already succeeded
in getting the states,
the Congress, and the executive branch
to endorse this concept, not that hard,
then, to get the Supreme Court to do it.
But what sparked them to do
it was, from their standpoint,
a loss, a big loss in the Gun Control Act.
So they, the NRA understands
the democratic underpinnings
of constitutional rights,
another story I tell
in that book is the story of
the marriage equality folks.
How did marriage equality
go from unthinkable,
which is what it was in, 25 years ago,
to inevitable, which
is what it was in 2015,
when the Supreme Court
decided that there indeed is
a constitutional right
to marriage equality?
And the answer is the same, the NRA, no,
the answer is the same, it is
civil society organizations,
who took a vision that
was rejected in the law,
and worked in a variety
of forums, through people,
to advance a different conception
that made it possible
to prevail on the claim.
So, in 1972, a gay couple argued
that they had a right to be married,
and they relied on the
equal protection clause
of the constitution, and
the due process clause
the Supreme Court thought
so little of the argument
that they dismissed it
with a single sentence, and said,
"It doesn't even raise a serious
question," that was 1972.
2015, the court recognized
a constitutional right
to marry, on the basis of what?
Equal protection, and
the due process clause,
the exact same arguments, so
the arguments didn't change,
the court, the court changed, right,
the court in 2015 was different
from the court in 1972,
but if anything, the court
in 2015 was more conservative
than the court in 1972,
that was the tail end
of the Warren court.
2015 was, you know, the Roberts court,
and yet, the court in 2015
recognized the right, so the law,
the legal arguments didn't
change, the court, if anything,
changed to become more conservative,
so what explains the change?
What explains the change
is the world changed,
and how did the world
change, the world changed
because groups like
Lambda Legal Defense Fund,
Freedom to Marry, gay and
lesbian advocates and defenders,
the ACLU Gay and Lesbian Rights Project,
worked collectively,
incrementally, patiently,
over 30 years to establish
steps on the road
to recognizing marriage equality.
And they didn't go for
it in one fell swoop,
they did in incrementally,
they started in the states,
they got progressive cities
to recognize domestic
partnerships for gay couples,
they got progressive counties
to pass anti-discrimination laws
that included sexual
orientation, they got some courts
and some progressive states
to recognize gay families in,
under family law, and
adoption rules, and the like.
And only then did they make an argument
that there's a right to marriage,
and they made it first in Vermont,
in a state court, on state
constitutional grounds,
and, and won civil unions there,
and then took it to Massachusetts,
and made the same, same
arguments in Massachusetts
on state constitutional grounds,
not federal constitutional grounds,
'cause if they made a federal
constitutional argument,
it could go to the Supreme Court,
where they knew they would lose.
And so they kept it to the states,
where the, the state
supreme court is the final,
is the final arbiter.
But there, too, what, what sort
of launched this whole movement
for gay rights was a series of losses,
the murder, the homophobic murder
of Matthew Shepard, the AIDs crisis,
and the failure and
refusal of the government
to do enough to respond to a crisis
that was specifically affecting,
at that time, anyway, the gay community.
Along the way, proposition eight, right,
which people in this room remember,
proposition eight, when the Supreme Court
of California recognized
marriage equality,
it was put on the ballot, and in 2008,
in the most liberal state in the country,
maybe except for Vermont, California,
in a year when Barack Obama was elected,
the first black president was elected,
marriage equality lost,
lost in a popular
referendum in California.
That was a devastating loss, but it,
it sparked a renewed
commitment to engage in
activism to advance the
notion of marriage equality,
and it caused the groups to
reconsider how they were arguing
for marriage equality, and
shifting from a rights framework
in their arguments to a love
and commitment framework,
which was much, turned out
to be much more effective
at bringing persuadable people,
people on the fence to their side.
So, so dark times
can often
inspire
people to come together and act in ways
that, advance the ball
from their perspective,
whether it's an ACLU and
first amendment rights,
whether it's the NRA, and
the right to bear arms,
or gay rights groups,
and marriage equality.
So,
so in a very real sense,
how this period will
ultimately be seen is up to us.
It is possible that this is the first step
on the road to authoritarianism
in the United States,
certainly Donald Trump
exhibits all the features
of authoritarian leaders,
but it is also possible
that we will look back
on this period 10 years
from now as a dark time that, nonetheless,
inspired and catalyzed the citizenry
to step up
and speak out in favor of
visions of civil rights
and civil liberties
that reflect this country
at its, at its best.
And I think we've seen many signs of that,
the most recent sign of that, I think,
is the high school
students who've responded
to the mass shooting in Florida, how?
By engaging in citizen activism,
and it's quite possible that they will
shift the debate
on gun rights and gun control
in a direction that favors a gun control,
but the very willingness of
them to get out there and speak,
this is not the first shooting,
mass shooting at a high
school, the very willingness
of them to take this action
up in their own hands,
in their own voices, I
think is a reflection
of what they have seen since
Donald Trump was elected,
in the women's march, in
the airport demonstrations,
in the DACA demonstrations,
in the town halls around the
ACA, in the special elections,
and now, in the effort
to advance gun control.
So one of the things
we've done at the ACLU is
to recognize that the fight
here is not simply a legal fight
in the courts, it is a fight of all of us,
and those 1.75 million people
who have come to join us,
they don't want, just want that card,
you know, in the mail, or emailed to them.
They don't just want to get, you know,
an inordinate number of email
action alerts in their inbox,
they actually want to take action.
So one of the things we did was
to create something called a People Power,
which has, I think, an
unfortunately sort of
'60s kind of a name to it,
it seems a little old-fashioned to me,
but we created People Power.
And what People Power is
is a platform to encourage
and facilitate local activism
by citizens who care about civil liberties
and civil rights in a coordinated fashion,
but a decentralized and
local, through decentralized
and local action.
And so the first campaign,
which was launched
with a video, an hour-long
video presentation done,
shot live in Miami, Florida,
was about sanctuary cities,
it was about getting citizens together
to encourage their towns and cities
to adopt sanctuary policies.
And over a million
people watched the video,
people watched it in house
parties across this country
in every state, multiple house parties,
and then we gave them
suggestions for how to go out
and seek to encourage
their local governments
to respect the rights of immigrants.
The same, the same thing,
the most recent campaign is a
campaign about voting rights,
let the people vote, and we have, again,
we launched it through a video,
a live videotape presentation
that people were invited
to watch in house parties across
this country, and they did.
And we have state specific campaigns
in all 50 states that people can take up
and act upon, and that's, I think,
a tremendous, tremendously important part,
it is grassroots mobilization
in defense of civil liberties.
Why is the NRA so
powerful, it is so powerful
because it has not 1.75 million members,
but five million members,
and it has 15 million others
who think they're members,
but don't pay their dues.
And when I interview the
NRA officials about this,
they said, "Well, we'd
love to have their dues,
"but what we really want is for them
"to identify as NRA members,
"because that means we
have 20 million people
"that we can reach out to to engage
"when we think gun
rights are under attack."
And so they have 20
million people, one right.
We have 1.75 million
people, the whole rest
of the Bill of Rights, so
we've still got a ways to go,
but what they have, what they've shown is
that the strongest support of civil rights
and civil liberties is not the court,
but it is the people, and indeed,
even after the Supreme Court
recognized an individual right
to bear arms, in the
DC versus Heller case,
in 2008, it is not the second amendment
that stops, that protects gun rights,
and stops gun control
legislation, it is the NRA,
because the NRA is able to stop laws
from getting enacted that would
clearly be constitutional,
and it is able to get laws enacted
that protect gun rights that
clearly would not be required.
The court in the Heller
case didn't say you can't
regulate guns, it said guns are subject
to reasonable regulation,
and they gave all kinds of examples.
So it's the political check of the NRA,
not the constitutional check of the courts
that is the ultimate
protector of that right.
And what may happen now is that the
high school students may give
impetus to a similar local,
you know, a state by state campaign
to push back against the NRA, something
that we really haven't
had in this country yet.
So People Power is one of
the ways that we've responded
to Trump, another way we've responded is
through social media,
and, you know, here, Donald
Trump has shown us the power
of social media, right?
He can speak directly
to the American people
through his Twitter account,
for better or for worse.
But it's not just Donald
Trump that can do that,
I, in my second week on the job,
I sat in on a meeting
of our coms department,
our communications department,
and it was amazing,
it was like, it was like
being in a newsroom.
There were 30 people, and
they'd get up, and say,
"Well, this is, this is the
video we created this week,
"and this is the issue that we're pushing,
"and we got this interview,
and that interview,
"and this many hits,
and here's what happened
"on the piece of legislation
"that was at issue in this state."
And it was, it was remarkable,
and I said to them,
you know, "When I started
out as a civil rights lawyer
"with the Center for
Constitutional Rights,
"a scrappier, smaller version of the ACLU,
"back in the 1980s, we
had a coms department,
"it was one guy, he was the PR guy."
And what would he do, he
would file a press release
when we filed a lawsuit, he
when we had a hearing, he
would file a press release
when we won a lawsuit,
and sometimes he'd file
a press release even
when we lost a lawsuit, right, but,
and what was he doing
with those press releases?
Trying to get the media,
especially The New York Times,
to cover our cases,
well, we still do that,
we still try to get The New
York Times to cover our cases,
and they do, but we can
speak to the people directly.
We have, you know, incredible
reach now through Facebook,
and Twitter, and Instagram,
that we can speak
to the people directly,
and in that coms meeting
of the, of the, you know, 30 or so causes
that we were advancing in that prior week,
through the various campaigns,
maybe 15% of them were cases
that we'd actually filed.
But 85% of them were
issues we cared about,
and that we were fighting on,
but we were fighting
through public education,
through mobilizing people,
not through relying on courts.
And that has led to some really, I think,
interesting work by the, by the ACLU.
Here's one campaign we
did, we took out ad space,
this is in Times Square, in New York,
for an ad, and the text there,
for those of you who can
read Arabic, you'll know,
so I don't need to tell you,
for those of you who can't read Arabic,
the text is the first amendment
of the United States constitution.
And we, it was a billboard that changed,
and it went from English
to Spanish to Arabic,
just the text of the first amendment.
We also, oh, this is the
women of the ACLU dressed
in their Vogue costumes, excellent.
Those blue ribbons, this
is Lin-Manuel Miranda,
and Emma Stone,
wearing ACLU blue ribbons
at the Academy Awards,
again, never before in the history
of our organization have we
had anything like this kind
of support, but it was our
communications department
that reached out to people,
and came up with this idea
of let's give a shout out
to the work of the ACLU,
from voices that people pay attention to,
whether they are, you know,
likely collaborators or not.
This is a little video
that announces a education
campaign we did about the,
about the Muslim ban one year
after it had been put in place.
(slow ambient music)
So,
and then, if you go to that site,
what we did was collect the stories
of people whose lives had been disrupted,
like the woman who tells that
story, by the Muslim ban.
So other than the fact that
we use "impact" as a verb,
which I cannot stand, a
fantastic effort to get people,
to reach people by telling stories
about the real life
impacts of these abuses,
and to encourage this
continuing involvement.
So let me,
let me, I'm coming to a close,
I want to show you this video,
which is one we made
at the end of the year,
to mark the first year
of the Trump campaign,
and I think it says, you know,
more eloquently than I just have,
what I've been talking about,
and then I'll have two
more words, and we'll be,
and I'd love to hear your questions.
(slow music)
- We are here doing some
hard work for our big march,
January 21st, 2017, we have
to make our voices heard.
(slow music)
- [Woman] Any woman's
right is a human right,
it's very important
that we stand together,
march in solidarity.
- [Crowd] No ban, no fear,
get the (mumbles) off of here.
No hate, no fear,
Muslims are welcome here!
- [Reporter] Yeah, many
bodega owners rallying
and praying in response to the
president's immigration ban,
hundreds have closed their
stores this afternoon.
- [Woman] We're joining up to
write a bunch of postcards,
figuring out what we can do,
what resources we have as a community.
- [Reporter] In Tempi, a special kind
of bake sale this weekend.
- [Reporter] This bake sale
is more about community,
sharing culture, and helping
refugees build a life
in a new place.
- [Reporter] Hundreds of
(mumbles) students walk out
of school, their message,
we stand with Dreamers.
(slow music)
- [Reporter] From coast to coast,
the players putting on
an unprecedented display
of solidarity for their league.
- I have never talked
about my case in public.
- This is probably the first time
I've ever really talked about it.
- It happened to me, too.
- To me, too.
- Me, too.
(slow music)
- Speaking your truth is the
most powerful tool we all have.
The new day is on the horizon!
(audience cheers)
(slow music)
- So, you know, I think that
does, just seeing those images,
and, for some reason,
you only got the music,
but not the actual voices,
it just, it reminds us
of how many incredible
movements have been launched
since Donald Trump was elected.
From the, from immigrants protections
to the women's march,
to the Me, Too moment,
to the successful struggle
to oppose the repeal
of Obamacare, even
though Trump had control
of both houses of Congress,
to the most recent efforts
of high school students to
respond to mass shootings.
It's really pretty remarkable, and to me,
that is where our salvation lies,
and so I'll close with a
quote from Learned Hand,
Learned Hand was a judge
on the United States Court
of Appeals for the Second Circuit,
he's often said to be
greatest federal judge not
to have served on the Supreme Court.
Now that my wife is a federal judge,
I can't agree with that, but
he was a pretty good judge,
and he made a speech in 1942 to
a crowd of 150,000 newly
naturalized citizens,
and this was a remarkable
naturalization ceremony,
it was held in Central
Park, 150,000 immigrants
who had taken the oath to become citizens,
and they asked Learned Hand
to address these new members
of our polity, and he
decided to speak about
liberty.
And he said
that, "Liberty lies in the hearts
"of men and women, when it lies there,"
or, no.
"When it dies there, no
court, no constitution,
"no law can save it,
but when it lies there,
"it needs no court, no constitution,
"no law to save it."
And like many great quotes,
it's an overstatement,
we need courts, we need a
constitution, we need laws,
they instantiate our
ideals, and hold us to them
in moments when we fall short.
But it recognizes a critical truth,
and that is that the ultimate protector
of
liberty is us,
and so, to me,
what is most hopeful about this moment
is that us, we, have stood
up like never before,
in my
lifetime, as a citizen, to come together
in defense of basic civil
liberties and civil rights.
And so I'm, I feel privileged
to be part of that battle,
but I am buoyed by the fact that so many
of our fellow citizens
are part of that battle,
and I hope all of you will be part of
that battle going forward,
thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you very much for
that wonderful set of remarks.
If you're willing, could
we take a few questions?
- Yeah, sure.
- So I'm gonna put this microphone here,
anyone who wants to ask a question,
please come to the microphone,
they can form a little line,
I only make two requests of you.
First, please keep your questions short,
and second, please ask a question.
(audience laughs)
Okay.
- And if you do that, I'll
keep my answers short,
and give an answer.
- [Man] Thanks for your presentation,
I'm actually one of
the defendants from the
2016 Republican National
Convention flag burning case,
along with Joey Johnson,
from Texas v. Johnson's
a good friend of mine.
- Yep, my former client.
- [Man] So I'm very familiar both
with the authoritarian attacks
that have been happening,
but also, our cases were
dropped, and all the ways
in which the courts
have beaten back, and I,
beaten back these various attacks on lots
of different fronts,
and I appreciate the way
that you talked about the combination
of civil society activism, along with,
you know, the legal battles in the courts.
My question is about the actual dynamic
that's been happening where, yes,
things have been beaten
back on various fronts,
but the Trump regime keeps pushing forward
on many other fronts,
including finding other ways,
you know, besides just the Muslim ban,
whether it's extreme
vetting, or whether it's,
you know, different, other restrictions,
and ways to keep people
from those countries.
And on top of that,
there's the question of,
you know, using incidents
in the same way you talked
about in the, the Palmer raids,
they used those terrorist
bombings, there's, I mean,
look at what Bush used
9/11 to do, can you imagine
if there's some incident like that now,
with this guy in the White House?
So my question is, I guess I agree with
the, the hope that you have,
but I also think we have
to confront how dangerous
the situation is,
and rather than just fighting
against each separate attack
on people, don't we need
to actually mobilize all
those people that were in the airports,
that were at the women's
march, don't we need
to mobilize them to drive the
regime from power altogether?
- So, you know, I think,
yeah, there are many,
there are many attacks,
the Trump administration
has gone after many targets,
and so it's a challenge.
I mean, you know, we have,
because we're a multi issue organization,
we're, we've been able to
respond to many of them,
but there are plenty
that we can't respond to,
the environment attacks, the, you know,
the environment groups are responding to.
There are a whole host of organizations
that are fighting back in various ways,
and I think it takes the
work of all of us to do it.
In terms of, you know, getting
the regime out of power,
that's what elections are
for, there will be midterms,
I think, you know, the, I'm optimistic
about the midterms, about the possibility
of people who believe in civil rights
and civil liberties getting elected,
and that will put a further
constraint on the president.
I'm optimistic about
2020, when we get there.
You know, Donald Trump was elected with,
losing the popular vote, he
got three million fewer votes
than Hillary Clinton, he won because
of the peculiarity of
our electoral college.
He came into office with
the lowest approval rating
of any president in history,
and his approval rating
has fallen since then.
So,
in a democracy, that is a significant
hindrance
to getting done what you want to get done.
Most of what he's gotten done is
through unilateral executive action,
and the thing about
unilateral executive action is
that there's quite a bit of room
for unilateral executive
action, but it can be reversed
by the next president, if we
elect a president who cares
about civil rights and civil liberties.
So I think the response is
through the democratic process,
and, you know, as to the
risk of a terrorist incident,
absolutely, that's a concern, but look,
you know, George Bush had more, more,
more going for him than President Trump.
He did not, when 9/11 happened,
he had a Congress on his side,
he had the court on his side, in fact,
it was the court that put him into office
through Bush versus
Gore, it was his court.
And he had a history of
deference to the president
in times of crisis, and he
had 90% approval ratings.
And yet, by the time, and he acted in,
he over-responded to the attacks on 9/11,
and authorized torture,
and disappearances,
and Guantanamo and the like,
but by the time he left office,
he had released over 500
people from Guantanamo,
he had closed down the secret
prisons in eastern Europe,
he had suspended the torture program,
he had stopped extraordinary rendition,
where we abducted people, and sent them
to other countries to be tortured.
And he did that in
response to civil society
advocacy
that made it too costly for
him to continue those efforts,
in particular, because foreign
countries were unwilling
to work with him because
he was so tainted by these,
these acts, so if we could
push back against George Bush,
who had 90% approval ratings,
surely we can push back
against Donald Trump,
who doesn't, can't even
command a majority, yeah?
- [Woman] Hello, thank
you for your speech.
I'm just a local activist
grassroots person,
I happen to do a lot of work
for Organizing for Action,
the former Obama group,
which is very issues based,
and the thing that strikes
me the most is yes,
I thought the day he was elected,
that it would incite enough people
to fight back, but the thing is,
that he's the great creator of chaos,
and he has siloed off all the people
into all the various issues,
so we have, you know,
he's great at just throwing a
new issue out there every day
on Twitter, you know, if he
can't get healthcare through,
he's talking about taking
a knee at the NFL game.
So my question to you is, given the fact
that his strategy seems to
be to go after grassroots
by dividing and conquering,
and creating a thousand issues,
so I'm fighting for DACA
today, and tomorrow,
you know, you're fighting
for the Muslim ban,
whatever it is, what can the ACLU do,
'cause there's strength in
numbers, we're Warriors fans,
what can the ACLU contribute
to bringing strength
in numbers, bringing us together,
because united we stand,
and divided we fall,
and that's one of his key strategies.
- So that's a great
question, and, and I think,
you know, it's the key question,
and I don't think, at the end of the day,
it's the ACLU that will do
that, we are trying to do that,
People Power is especially
trying to do that.
We work in coalitions
across the board to try
to foster progressive movements,
and,
and strengthen the opposition
to, to these abuses,
but at the end of the day, you know,
I think it's got to be
the Democratic party,
you know, that, which is a
big tent across the board
of organization, it's not focused, I mean,
we're broad-based for civil
liberties and civil rights,
but we don't deal with the environment,
we don't deal with, you
know, regulation of business,
particularly, we don't
deal with the distribution
of wealth, a huge issue
in this country, right?
So it can't be our organization,
and there is no, the only organization
that really is across the board,
that has the capacity to be a,
to stand against the president
is the Democratic party,
I think, and, you know,
I'm not overly impressed
by the Democratic party's work thus far,
in standing up, but I
think at the, you know,
when it comes to the
midterms, you're gonna see all
of this energy, you know, the
energy that's been directed
at immigrant's rights, and
towards the Me, Too moment,
and around gun control.
All of that energy is gonna come together
in support of candidates who
care about civil liberties
and civil rights, they might be Democrat,
they might be Republican,
but it'll be candidates
who stand against what
Donald Trump stands for,
and that's how we come together.
But I agree, we need, we
need, we need messages
that unite us, and, you
know, I think civil rights
and civil liberties is a
message that can unite us,
because it's ultimately
predicated on a set of rights
that are owed to all of us
by virtue of our being human.
They're not the rights of progressives,
they're not the rights of liberals,
they're the rights of all of us,
and so that, and one of the ways
that we define ourselves as Americans is
by virtue of the values and rights
that are reflected in our constitution,
and the Bill of Rights
is one set of those.
So I think it can be a unifying force,
but it can't be the only
unifying force, thanks.
- [Man] First, thank you
for your wonderful talk.
You mentioned in your discussion
of the first amendment
the Brandenburg test,
which defines the outer bounds of
what is protected free
speech, and the fact
that Brandenburg was
a Ku Klux Klan leader.
I'm gonna go to a meeting,
I'm not a member of the NLG,
but right after this, about
the new FBI designation
called Black Identity Extremist,
I wonder if you could speak
to the notion that the ACLU
should prioritize and continue
to defend the most really
vicious and virulent
and offensive hate
speech, as long as it is
within the bounds of the Brandenburg test,
so that a deterioration
of the Brandenburg test,
if it were to happen, could not be used
against black activists who could then be
called black identity extremists,
and accused of fomenting
violence, and all the rest.
So I think that there's,
it's a lively discussion,
but I wonder if you could
speak to that discussion,
and where the ACLU
stands, and in particular,
well, that's, on that, thank you.
- So, so, yeah, thank
you for that question,
you know, the ACLU has long, again,
we defend the Bill of
Rights, we defend the rights
that are reflected in the Bill of Rights,
which are ultimately human rights,
they are owed to everybody,
and we will defend them
on behalf of anybody,
so, so we defend the right to speak
of civil rights activists,
but we also defend the right
to speak of white
supremacists, and I think,
you know, if you are committed
to a principled defense
of the first amendment,
it can't be any other way.
The first amendment is not, if
the first amendment was just
about protecting those
with whom you agree,
it wouldn't be a human right, right?
It would be a right of,
of a particular subset
of the country, so, so I
think a principled stand
in defense of the first amendment requires
that one recognize that
the right extends not only
to the people with whom you agree,
but the people with whom you disagree.
And in a democracy, it is ultimately,
the first amendment is
ultimately a protection
of the minority, right, it is a protection
of those who don't have
power in democracy,
who don't have a majority vote.
And it's a critically
important protection,
because it's what, it's what gives those
of us who are not in power,
those of us who are unhappy
with the status quo, a
way to voice our concern,
and to act on our
concern, it is, you know,
the engine of that resistance
that I've been celebrating here.
And if we were to advance a
position that says, actually,
the first amendment only protects
the speech we like, well,
who would be deciding
which speech we like?
It wouldn't be minority groups,
it wouldn't be dissidents,
it would be the majority,
it would be Donald Trump,
it would be the mayor of
the town in Mississippi,
it would be the governor
of Arkansas, right,
it would be the people who are in power,
and you can be sure that the speech
that they would suppress is likely to be
the kind
of speech that we want
heard, not the kind of speech
with which we disagree.
So I think on grounds of principle,
and on grounds of democratic practice,
it's important to protect
speech rights of all.
On campus, and off.
- [Man] Again, thank you,
I appreciated your voice
of optimism of the phoenix
rising from the ashes
of this past election, and
I hope it comes to pass,
and I try to think back
to McCarthyism as an era
that we no longer have to deal with,
and maybe someday we'll look
back at this era the same way.
My question concerns one
of the issues you raised,
you mentioned, in terms
of one of the pillars
that are protecting us is the media,
you briefly mentioned it.
- Yeah.
- [Man] The issue there that concerns me,
and I'd like your reaction
to, is the whole issue
of fake news, and the attempt by Trump,
in particular, and right
wing extremism in general,
to create an alternate
universe where we begin
to question whether we can
call anything a fact anymore,
you know, you read articles about, we live
in a fact-free society
right now, and so on,
and how, when you have Fox News,
that will be promoting
things that seem contrary
to common sense often,
and a Republican party,
when you look at poles
where they believe something
with 85% assurance, where the rest
of the country is something like 15%,
and it just seems like,
and the similar issue
of, of the, of the
interference in social media
by Russians and so on that could affect,
you know, you talk
about how you're hopeful
that the next election will bring change,
but maybe we won't even
have a fair next election.
And so I guess my question is can you,
you know, what is your
reaction to all that?
- So.
(audience laughs)
You guys are insistent on
being pessimistic, huh, so.
(audience laughs)
No, that, all, all really good questions,
and social media is a,
you know, it's really the,
you know, it's the
democratization of media.
The fact that anybody, to some degree,
can now be a media outlet, you know,
in many ways it's empowering, you know,
you never would have had
those airport demonstrations
without social media, it was the only way
that people spontaneously ran out
to airports on that weekend
was because of a Twitter storm
that got people, you know, out there.
So it's a powerful tool, it's
a powerful tool for good,
it's a powerful tool for
bad, and it frees up speakers
to speak without editorial control,
which creates the possibility of all kinds
of falsehood and the
like, and that's a cost
of democracy, and I'm not exactly sure
what the best way to respond to it is,
I, you know, I tend to be suspicious about
suggestions
that we empower a platform,
you know, like Facebook,
or Twitter, to decide
what's fake and what's
true, but it also seems,
you know, in the same way that we're,
we don't trust the government
to make the right decision
about what's false and what's true,
why would we, you know,
trust Mark Zuckerberg
to make that determination?
And so, you know, I tend
to think that the best,
the best answer is still
to let 1,000 flowers bloom,
and to hope that truth counters falsehood,
but it's hard to keep one's faith in that,
in the wake of the kind of echo chamber
that we're all part of,
and it's not just Fox News,
it's, you know, there are
certain things you can't say
on Fox News, and must be said on Fox News,
and there are certain things
that you can't say on MSNBC,
and you must say on
MSNBC, are they are two,
you know, they are alternate universes,
and it is deeply troubling that we live
in these alternate universes.
I think, you know, the best we can do is
to encourage cross-fertilization,
to encourage those forms
of forums in which people
speak to each other,
in which people are confronted with ideas
that they disagree with, again,
one of the reasons I think
the first amendment is
so important, and tolerating
speech we don't like is
important is because
that's what, you know,
creates the exchange, which
our system is predicated on.
So I don't have the answers
to, you know, how we adjust,
or whether we adjust
first amendment principles
to social media, I agree
that it's a challenging,
it's a very challenging area,
and it's one we have to,
we have to
figure out.
But I also think it's
important to keep in mind
that as much of a danger
social media creates,
it also creates a tremendous opportunity
in giving forums for people
to express themselves
in ways that just weren't available when,
you know, The New York Times, CBS, ABC,
and NBC essentially
controlled the waterfront.
- [Man] Yeah, just to follow
up on the last questioner,
do you see a danger in
the whole Russia hysteria,
where apparently Russia's
behind everything bad
that ever happens in this country,
it was behind Bernie Sanders,
it was behind Jill Stein,
and is also what I see,
even in the wake of
Parkland, you know, calls for,
well, there were these
conspiracies being spread
in social media, so therefore
we gotta crack down on,
do you see a danger of
this, what I would call faux-resistance,
that's all channeled into
worrying about Russia,
and Russia undermining our democracy,
being used to suppress dissent, you know,
in a social, like you said,
you know, in a social media,
either through the companies themselves,
or pressure on them to,
you know, to crack down
on certain types of speech,
which I think will be
directed against dissenters.
- So I don't, I mean,
I think the danger is
that this government is
doing nothing about Russia,
you know, what we've seen, in
terms of Russia's interference
in our election, is outrageous,
and any president who had any,
you know, legitimate
concern for the future
of our democracy would respond seriously
to that, to that attack.
And instead, we have a
president who is unwilling
to take that threat seriously,
so I think it's a threat
we need to take seriously,
I think it's a, you know,
that one of the dangers
of social media is that it,
is that it is accessible
to people far beyond our borders,
who have no legitimate
voice in our democracy,
and, and are exercising that voice.
That problem, I think, we could solve,
I think, you know, dealing with bots,
identifying the sources of certain kinds
of news information,
and social media
interventions,
we could, we could
respond to that, I think.
But no, I think the problem
is quite the opposite,
that we're not doing enough to respond
to that problem, than
that we're doing too much.
- Thank you, I came in despondent,
and now maybe I'm a little bit hopeful?
(audience laughs)
To give you more hope, we
have refreshments in the back,
I hope you'll join us
in thanking David Cole.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat music)